est-ce qu'on peut faire entrer le témoin
et la personne qui a tamponné le scooter
merci non non mais non mais non c'est
pas ça du tout mais non oh là là qui
sont nuls en musique bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur
alors merci merci la personne alors il
s'appelle Guillaume bonsoir Guillaume
merci d'être là Guillaume toi tu peux
parler dans le micro merci Guillaume
d'être là
avant qu'on parle à Guillaume s'il vous
plaît on a eu un témoin parce que Sacha
était là qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
en scooter à la canal Factory là où on
enregistre l'émission enfin là où on est
en direct d'ailleurs et donc je vois un
scooter complètement fracassé au sol et
là je me dis et si c'était pas celui de
Benjamin parce qu'il faisait tout neuf
ton scoot Benjamin et donc là j'aperçois
ouais il était 9 fois du coup je je vois
un peu tout ça donc j'envoie un SMS à la
personne on voudrait bien ce qui s'est
passé ici et ben du coup le scooter
était complètement fracassé par Monsieur
et quand Benjamin est arrivé devant le
monsieur ensuite benjamin est sorti
quand vous avez dit de rejoindre un peu
la scène de ce qui s'est passé et là
Benjamin a complètement perdu ses ex ah
oui il a perdu ses couilles complètement
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé tu as donc
percuté un scooter
ici effectivement je devais livrer des
fleurs et apparemment voilà
parce que donc forcément Guillaume tu
veux tu comptes porter plainte contre
que ce scooter a tapé ton camion parce
qu'il était mal garé
voilà donc apparemment ce scooter t'a
empêché de faire ton travail
comptes-tu voilà poursuivre Benjamin
Castaldi pour se méfait non tu t'en sors
bien
tu t'en charger
Guillaume je vais faire quelque chose
que je ne fais jamais
pour le mal que tu as subi et je ne
rigole pas je t'offre un scooter
[Applaudissements]
merci Segway je t'offre un scooter je
t'offre vraiment un
scootera scooter
un scooter ma chérie mon chéri la seule
chose que je te demande vraiment
Guillaume ici on se dit tout et je vais
dire la vérité dis ce que tu as sur le
coeur avant d'avoir Castaldi qui a été
horrible
allez c'est très déçu
un scooter maintenant
je t'offre un scooter
merci bravo pour tout ce que tu fais
voilà merci merci
[Applaudissements]
les choses Benjamin vraiment voilà
heureusement que j'ai rangé ton histoire
tu peux me remercier une fois de plus